je présente les amendements pour le
projet de loi report des élections
régionales et départementales pour le
groupe mouvement démocrate et démocrate
apparenté la définition même du du
citoyen c'est celui qui vote
donc pour être citoyen il faut voter on
sait que l'abstention est de plus en
plus forte qu'elle augmente et le
dernier scrutin qui a lieu les
municipales de 2020 il ya eu une
abstention qui a été vraiment inédite
parce qu'en général les gens aiment bien
aller voter quand même pour pour choisir
leurs maires mais c'est important que
les gens puissent se mobiliser pour
voter pour leurs représentants
puisque c'est comme ça finalement qu'il
qu'il s'exprime on est dans une crise
sanitaire
c'est pour ça que effectivement on
reporte les élections
mais au-delà de cette crise sanitaire il
nous semble vraiment important de
pouvoir faciliter l'accès au vote
puisque vous pouvez avoir des problèmes
de mobilité vous pouvez avoir des
raisons pour lesquelles vous ne pouvez
pas vous rend physiquement dans des
bureaux de vote
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut qu'on
trouve vraiment des moyens de faciliter
l'accès au vote